and he but when saito sensei died and i
went to his wake
uh there was a little japanese man we
were on the train he starts talking
and i was fortunate enough to be with
somebody who could translate and he said
oh sensei said we don't use this word
but i think he said you must use
force
when i ask you to attack
if i should agree 100 force when i ask
you attack 100 percent he said and he
used to shout at us he said and and he
was about in his 70s then he said and i
still shake today
with remembering how much other sense he
shouted at us for not using 100 force
then the hombu the son decided that
he said to his sensei
they're not farm workers and railway
workers they're not built like tanks
these people they're bankers they're
students
we've got to change aikido to make it
more harmonious and more
health benefits
so that's really why we've now got the
the two main factors of iwama what's
looks stiff as a board and grips like
crazy
and we've got the flowing and the white
and if we can mix the two together then
i think we're going to start
understanding those senses i could have
is it really strong it's stupid isn't it
i'll say is it really strong i don't
feel people now look i don't feel
people's strength
is it knowledge is it power i don't know
but it's through this this this and and
this blocking that i've found
and it's techniques
it's it's techniques
so
nobody is strong
everybody is their self
everybody is theirself
so after the break we're going to do the
marauder door
and people don't listen i say to them
look this is what you see
but this is what's happening
i'm actually going the opposite way
i'm actually going the opposite way to
and then i come in
because you don't see it
you'll keep wondering why
god
you'll keep wondering why you're getting
blocked it's because you're going the
wrong way
remember the ken
please come pass
look
he doesn't feel the block
he's got a lovely grip though
so after breakfast after breakfast after
the break we'll we'll do murati dory
and we're going to go through because in
the past i haven't insisted on it but
we're going to go through the steps that
i go through so you realize
that
as you advance like you have done with
the kite nagi as you as you've learned
to ease off
this shoulder go see that small movement
that went to that corner
so when i go in
you only see the going in you don't see
where i put my mental direction
and that makes a difference and so
nobody to me is strong
because what i'm doing is i'm actually
saying i'm going to go over here and
then what i'm going to do is i'm
actually going to
he's turning back
i'm not really turning him
he's turning because i'm actually since
you used to go this is comfortable here
and then
move in
hopefully a lot of information we've got
it on film hopefully it'll be good
we'll finish